you mentioned startup
what do you think it takes to build a
successful startup yeah
that it's what what louise was saying
that um you need to in to be able to
endure being stuck
and and i think the best way to put it
is that startups
don't have a linear reward function
right you oftentimes don't get rewarded
for effort
and and in most of our lives we go
through these processes that do
uh give you those small rewards for
effort right in school you study hard
generally you'll get a good grade and
then you good you get like good grades
ever or you get grades every semester
and so you're you're slowly getting
rewarded and pushed in the right
direction
for for startups and startups are not
the only thing that is like this but
for startups it's you know you can put
in a ton of effort into something
that and then get no reward for it right
it's like like sisyphus boulder
where you're pushing that boulder up the
mountain
and and and you get to the top and then
it just rolls all the way back down
and and so that's something that i think
a lot of people are not equipped
to deal with and can be incredibly
demoralizing
especially if that happens more than
than a few times
and so but i think it's absolutely
essential to power through it because
by the nature of startups it's often
times you know you're dealing with
with with non-obvious ideas and things
that
there might be contrarian and so you're
gonna
you're gonna run into into that a lot
you're gonna do things that are not
gonna work out
uh and you need to be prepared to deal
with that but
but we're not coming out of college
you're you're just not equipped
i'm not sure if there's a way to train
people to deal with those
non-linear reward functions but it's
definitely i think one of the most
difficult things to
you know about doing a startup and also
happens in research sometimes you know
we're talking about the default studies
being stuck you just you know you don't
like you try things you get zero results
you close doors you
constantly closing doors until you you
know find something
and um yeah that is a big thing
what about sort of this point when
you're stuck there's a kind of decision
whether you if you have a vision to
persist
through through with this direction that
you've been going along
or what a lot of startups do or
businesses is pivot
how do you decide whether like to give
up
on a particular flavor of the way you've
imagined the design
and to like adjust it or completely
like alter it i think that's
a core question for startups that i've
asked myself exactly
and like i've never been able to come up
with a great framework to make those
decisions
um i think that's really at the core of
uh yeah out of a lot of the the toughest
questions
that that people that's that started a
company have to deal with
um i think maybe the best framework that
i i
was able to figure out like when you run
out of ideas
you just you know you're exploring
something it's not working you try it
in a different angle you know you try a
different business model
yeah when you run out of ideas like you
don't have any more cards
just switch and yeah
it's not perfect because you also it's
you have a lot of stories of startups
it's like people kept pushing and then
you know
that paid off and then you have uh
philosophies is like
fail fast and pivot fast um
so it's you know it's hard to you know
balance
these two worlds and understand what is
the best framework
and i mean if you look at firmware's
library you're
maybe you can correct me but it feels
like you're operating in a space
where there's a lot of things that are
broken and
or could be significantly improved so it
feels like there's
a lot of possibilities for pivoting
or like how do you revolutionize science
how do you revolutionize
the aggregation the the
annotation the commenting the community
around information
about knowledge structured knowledge i
mean that's kind of what like stack
overflow
stack exchange has struggled with to
come up with a solution and they've come
up
i think with an interesting set of
solutions that are also i think
flawed in some ways but they're much
much better than the alternatives
but there's a lot of other possibilities
if we just look at papers as we talked
about there's so many possible
revolutions and they're
a lot of money to be potentially made in
those revolutions
plus coupled with that the benefit to
humanity
and so like you're sitting there like i
don't know how many people
are legitimately from a business
perspective playing with these ideas it
feels like
there's a lot of ideas here true there
is are you right now grinding in a
particular direction
like is there a like a five-year vision
that you're thinking in your mind
for us it's more like a 20-year vision
in the sense that
uh we we've consciously tried to make
the decision
of so we so we run fermat says
it's a side project and it's separate in
the sense like it's not
what we're working on full time and uh
but our thesis there is that
we actually think that it's that's a
good thing at least for
for this stage of vermont's library um
and also because
some of these projects you just
if you're coming from a start from a
startup framework
you probably try to
try to fit every single idea into
something that can change the world
within three to five years
and there's just some problems that take
longer than that
right and so you know we're talking
about archive and i'm very doubtful that
you could grow
like archive into what it is today like
within two or three years no matter how
much money you throw at it
there's just some things that can take
longer but you need to be able to power
through
the the the time that it takes um
but if you look at it as okay this is a
company this is a startup we have to
grow fast we have to raise money
then uh then sometimes you might forego
those ideas
because of that um because they don't
very well
fit into the the typical
startup framework and so for us for mats
it's something that we're
okay with growing with having it grow
slowly and and maybe taking
many years and and and that's why we
think it's
it's not a bad thing that it is a side
project because it makes it much more
um acceptable in a way and that
to to to be able to be okay with that
that said i think what happens is
if you keep pushing new little features
new little ideas
i feel like there's like certain ideas
will just become viral
like and then you just won't be able to
help yourself but
it'll revolutionize things it feels like
there needs to be
that needs to be but there's uh
opportunity for viral ideas to change
science absolutely and maybe we don't
know what those are yet
it might be a very small kind of thing
maybe you don't even know if
should this be a for-profit company
doing these this is the wikipedia
question
yeah um is that there are a lot of
questions like
really fundamental questions about this
space um that we've
we've talked about i mean you take
wikipedia and you try to run it as a
startup and by now we'd have a paywall
you'd be paying 9.99 a month to to read
more than 24
i mean that's that's one view yeah the
other
the ad driven model so they rejected the
ad driven model
i don't know if we could i mean this is
a difficult question
you know if archive was supported by ads
i don't know if that's bad for archive
if vermont's library was supported by
ads
i don't know i don't i'm not it's not
trivial to me i'm
unlike i think a lot of people uh i'm
not against
advertisements i think as when done well
are really good i think the problem with
facebook and all the social networks are
the way
the lack of transparency around the way
they use data
and uh the lack of control the users
have over their data and not the fact
that data is being collected and used
to sell advertisements it's a lack of
transparency lack of control if you
if you do a good job of that i feel like
it's really nice way to make stuff free
yeah it's like stack overflow right yeah
i think they've done an okay a good job
with that even though as we said like
they're
capturing very little of the value that
they're putting out there
right but but it makes it a sustainable
company and
and they're providing a lot of it's a
fantastic and very
productive community
you